un derby vinoy pour terminer l'année
2019 trappe recevait l'équipe réserve de
versailles à l'occasion de la 10e
journée de régionale 2 après une fin de
match à suspense les trappistes arrache
finalement le match nul score final un
but partout
on est rentré en deuxième mi temps avec
un visage un peu plus conquérant et on
avait à coeur de le ramener au minimum
seul point du match nul
c'est un match engagé contre
pour les deux équipes qui jouent le
maintien avec sa dette un combat c'est
difficile qui plus est avec un terrain
très compliqué donc le résultat nul me
semble logique
après ce résultat trap est toujours sous
la menace d'une relégation en fin de
saison les trappistes pointe à la 10e
place sur 12 équipes engagées
mais l'équipe termine l'année sur une
note positive depuis lors autour sur le
bandit shams et redit trappe reste sur
une série de deux victoires et deux nuls
en quatre matches on va se préparer au
mieux pour encore prendre des points au
maximum et s'éloigner de cette zone de
relégation
les moyens on les a les joueurs on les a
pour y arriver maintenant c'est une
lutte de tous les instants c'est un
marathon
donc on verra la fin le championnat de
régionale 2 reprendra le 19 janvier
prochain après une longue trêve trappe
ira défier ozoir de son côté à
versailles recevra val d'europe